und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend die Präsidentin der
EU-Kommission Ursula von der Leyen liebt
pathetische Worte und Gesten sie sind
einer von uns wir wollen sie drin haben
sagte sie kurz nach Kriegsbeginn und
meinte die Ukraine mit drin haben in der
EU das was heute passiert ist allerdings
mehr als nur Symbolik von der Leyen hat
sich mitsamt dem
EU-Außenbeauftragten und 14
eu-kommissarinnen und Kommissarin auf
den Weg ins Kriegsgebiet nach Kiew
gemacht um die Botschaft das Europa fest
an der Seite der Ukraine steht
wirkungsvoll zu unterstreichen was
nichts daran ändert dass ein EU-Beitritt
der Ukraine in weiter Ferne liegt Isabel
Schäfers berichtet über ein besonderes
Treffen in Kiew
Ursula von der Leyen hat ein Geschenk
mitgebracht und wohl nicht das was er
sich gewünscht hat Woody mehr silensky
wirkt fast irritiert
geben Sie uns die ja oder wollen Sie uns
die nur zeigen
wenigstens die EU-Flagge darf er schon
mal behalten darüber hinaus hat die
EU-Kommission vor allem symbolträchtige
Bilder im Gepäck und Durchhalteparolen
für ein Volk im Krieg
heute sind wir im Herzen Europas
zusammengekommen denn die Ukraine ist
das Zentrum unseres Kontinents geworden
der Ort an dem unsere Werte hochgehalten
werden unsere Freiheit verteidigt und
die Zukunft Europas geschrieben wird
fast die gesamte EU-Kommission ist heute
nach Kiew gereist um die ukrainische
Regierung zu treffen beide Seiten
überschütten sich mit netten Worten aber
klar wird auch die Ukraine will mehr
will EU-Mitglied werden
reichen Sieger auf dem Schlachtfeld
nicht aus wir brauchen auch den Glauben
an ein friedliches und ein vereintes
Europa
und wir brauchen die Stärke unserer
Institution
kurz vor dem Besuch aus Brüssel wurde
gestern die Wohnung eines Oligarchen
durchsucht hier fehlt zeigen wir machen
Ernst im Kampf gegen Korruption und
drängt heute auf ein schnellen
EU-Beitritt doch der Weg ist lang
konkrete Zusagen gibt es heute nicht
Ihre Bewerbung für die EU-Mitgliedschaft
haben sie brillant vorbereitet ich
erkenne ihre Bemühungen an auf
politischer Ebene schnell zu reagieren
und sicherzustellen dass die
Korruptionsbekämpfung greifbare
Ergebnisse bringt und weiter
intensiviert wird
ein paar konkrete Ankündigungen hat die
Kommission aber auch weitere 450
Millionen Euro sollen bereitgestellt
werden etwa für den schnellen
Wiederaufbau der Infrastruktur außerdem
soll das zehnte Sanktionspaket gegen
Russland noch vor Ende des Monats auf
den Weg gebracht werden
wir sehen dass sich das sanktionstempo
der EU etwas verlangsamt hat und dass
der russische Terrorstaat sich immer
schneller an die Sanktionen anpasst es
ist also wichtig dass wir uns
zusammenraufen und beeilen um die
Situation zu korrigieren
und so wird trotz Geschenken schöner
Bilder und warmer Worte klar es gibt
viele Erwartungen von der EU an die
Ukraine und derzeit vielleicht noch mehr
von der Ukraine an die EU
Katrin Eigendorf ist für uns in Kiew
guten Abend dorthin Katrin wie gucken
die Ukrainer eigentlich auf diese
beitrittsdiskussion glauben die daran
dass sie in zwei Jahren Mitglied der EU
sind
ja die Ukraine hat ja ihre politische
Zukunft wirklich an diese Mitgliedschaft
geknüpft man sieht sich hier als den
europäischen Staat das kann man wirklich
sagen wird geteilt von der Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung und man tut das durchaus
auch mit Selbstbewusstsein also die
Menschen mit denen wir hier reden und
auch die Regierungsmitglieder sehen sich
hier gar nicht als Bittsteller sondern
sagen immer wieder wir sind eigentlich
das Land das am meisten nach Europa
gehört von allen weil kein Land ist so
sehr bisher für die Werte Europas
eingetreten wie wir in der Ukraine wir
führen hier Krieg um eigentlich die
Kernwerte der Europäischen Union um
Rechtsstaatlichkeit um Demokratie um
einen freien Markt und deswegen man
sieht die Perspektive hier schon sehr
klar dass man nach Europa gehört aber
man muss natürlich auch realistisch
genug sein dass auch die Ukraine trotz
allem die Kriterien dafür erfüllen wird
aber die Gesten die man heute hier
gesehen hat bestätigt natürlich wo Leute
die mir und seine Regierung auch darin
dass sie hier durchaus selbstbewusst
agieren können denn das ist natürlich
ein sehr sehr weitreichendes Symbol das
hier eine so große Delegation von
Kommissaren in ein Land im Krieg fährt
danke erstmal Katrin bis hierhin bleibt
bei uns wir sprechen gleich weiter
während Europa also mit viel Symbolik
die Ukraine unterstützt feiert Russland
mit noch mehr Pathos das Ende der
Schlacht um Stalingrad heute vor 80
Jahren katapultierten kapitulierten etwa
100.000 deutsche Wehrmachtsoldaten nach
monatelangem Häuserkampf aus diesem Sieg
über Hitlers Armee zieht Russland bis
heute sein Selbstverständnis als
Großmacht eigens für die Feierlichkeiten
wurde eine neue stadienbüste enthüllt
und Insassen von Gefängnissen an die
Orte der Schlacht geführt der Tag ist so
wichtig dass auch Leute die mir Putin
der nur noch selten reist nach Wolgograd
kam und sich zum ersten Mal zu Lieferung
deutscher Kampfpanzer an die Ukraine
äußerte Christiansen
heute war einer dieser seltenen Tage für
Wladimir Putin an dem er der Meinung war
dass ich eine Reise lohnt 80 Jahre nach
dem Sieg der Sowjetunion gegen die Nazis
in der Schlacht von Stalingrad also
Wladimir Putin in Wolgograd seine Rede
hält nutzt er wieder einen für Russland
wichtigen Feiertag für seine Propaganda
und tut damit genau das was ihm seine
Kritiker immer wieder vorwerfen
unglaublich aber wahr wir werden wieder
von deutschen Leopard-Panzern bedroht
die Kreuze tragen
im Zweiten Weltkrieg gab es zwar kein
Leopard Panzer aber es wird schon klar
welchen Vergleich Putin da ziehen will
kritische Stimmen sind in Russland fast
verstummt doch es gibt sie noch wir
treffen Alexander jefimo von der
oppositionsparteiabloco die russische
Führung eignen sich Feiertage an und
entwerte sie so für alle und er sieht
eine gefährliche Entwicklung wenn so wie
gestern eine neue stalinstatue
aufgestellt wird oder die Wünsche lauter
werden Wolgograd wieder in Stalingrad
umzubenennen
wir sehen eine Wiedergeburt politischer
Repressalien und politischer
Verfolgungen im Land ja und dieses
Denkmal symbolisiert die Rückkehr zu den
repressiven Praktiken eine Rückkehr zum
Totalitarismus das ist sehr schlimm
eine Passanten die bei unserem Interview
mithört ruft die Polizei wir würden Hass
gegen den Staat verbreiten erzählt sie
den Beamten nach kurzer Prüfung lassen
Sie uns und den oppositionellen gehen
wir fahren zu einer Beerdigung in
Wolgograd werden auch 80 Jahre nach der
Schlacht noch sterbliche Überreste
gefunden und beigesetzt zur gleichen
Zeit jetzt sich bald der russische
Angriff auf die Ukraine
sehr traurig dass wir jetzt
gegeneinander kämpfen das liegt an den
Politikern an politischen Gruppierungen
in der Ukraine die Russland in jeder
Weise aus der Geschichte streichen
wollen
genau dieses narrativ wird von der
russischen Propaganda immer wiederholt
und das Russland in der Ukraine wieder
gegen Nazis Kämpfe wiederholt auch Putin
heute in wolgograf
und sie werden wieder gegen Russland auf
dem Territorium der Ukraine kämpfen mit
den Handlangern von Hitlers Anhängern
den banderiten
Putin droht an diesem Feiertag dann noch
dem Westen mit der Anwendung von
Panzertechnik sei die Sache nicht
erledigt das solle jeder verstehen
[Applaus]
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat heute
Abend auf Putins Rede reagiert er setze
auf die Diplomatie und werde auch weiter
mit dem russischen Präsidenten
telefonieren der müsse seine Truppen aus
der Ukraine zurückziehen und damit
zurück zu Katrin Eigendorf nach Kiew
Katrin wie nimmt man denn in Kiew diese
Jubiläumsfeiern in Russland war wo ja
der Sieg über die Ukraine immer
mitgedacht wird
ja das war hier heute kein wichtiges
Thema das Präsident Putin die Geschichte
missbraucht um seinen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine zu rechtfertigen das ist
nichts Neues für die Ukrainer eine
wirkliche Stellungnahme von Top-Leuten
aus der Regierung ist bisher
ausgeblieben es haben aber einige
Parlamentarier das kommentiert und diese
Kommentare sind auch nicht neu da heißt
es im Prinzip dieses wieder beziehe man
auf Putin Putin führe das was Hitler
gemacht habe im Prinzip jetzt gegen die
Ukraine durch nämlich einen
Angriffskrieg einen brutalen
Vernichtungskrieg gegen die ukrainische
Bevölkerung das ist die Stellungnahme
und die Haltung von einigen
Parlamentariern die das hier auf
sozialen Medien veröffentlicht haben in
den sozialen Netzwerken findet man aber
auch eine
gewissen Sport gegenüber Putin das muss
man sagen also man nimmt sagen wir mal
dieses diese Haltung die der russische
Präsident hier verkörpert in Teilen der
Bevölkerung auch gar nicht mehr wirklich
ernst deswegen also ein wichtiges Thema
war das was in volgrad heute passiert
ist hier in Kiew nicht vielen Dank
Katrin nach Kiew
Vladimir Putin und sein
propaganda-apparat ziehen also mit der
Schlacht von Stalingrad eine genauso
schiefe wie empörende Parallele zum
Krieg in der Ukraine auch dort Kämpfe
Russland ja gegen ukrainische Nazis so
die russische Sicht und immer wieder
werde Russland gegen die von Deutschland
unterstützten Nazis gewinnen
das Russland der Aggressor ist egal
Tatsache ist 80 Jahre nach Stalingrad
tobt ein echter Krieg in Europa und eine
ebenso fürchterliche propagandaschacht
Christa Läpple über das Dickicht der
Lüge
mitten im Herzen von Berlin das
sowjetische Ehrenmal Symbol für den
sieg-stahl ins über Hitler Deutschland
aus den Trümmern der Reichskanzlei
errichtet soll das Mahnmal der Roten
Armee zum Frieden Mann ein paar Blumen
sind zum Gedenken an die Schlacht von
Stalingrad niedergelegt mehr nicht kaum
zu glauben für Moskau ist Deutschland
wieder naziland die Propaganda gegen
Deutschland
gegen die deutschen Panzer die jetzt
angeblich wieder mit eisernem Kreuz
durch die Ukraine Rollen gefolgt
angeblich nur von den Gaskammern die die
deutschen dann in die Ukraine liefern
also zynischer und schlimmer kann man es
glaube ich gar nicht
beschreiben seit der deutschen
panzerzusage für die Ukraine verstärkt
die Kreml Propaganda ihr Trommelfeuer
schlimmer als im Kalten Krieg sagen
Experten
Scholz Scholz lass dir einen Hitler
wachsen
am deutschen folgen was bist du das bist
du und nicht deutscher Kanzler
Scholz sie bandera bandizi liefern
Deutschland
Berlin wird zerstört in Deutschland
weiter Waffen an die ukrainischen Nazis
liefert ukratzt wird das in Russland
geglaubt leider also Wladimir den sie
gezeigt haben ist eine unglaubliche
Dreckschleuder wir machen uns in
Deutschland keine Vorstellung wie
Propaganda funktioniert und an diesen
Sonntagabend Sendungen ist das
eigentlich seit Monaten seit Jahren der
Fall und wir haben in Deutschland leider
nie auf die Art und Weise geschaut wie
Propaganda funktioniert wir müssen das
sehr ernst nehmen
Säbelrasseln und weltkriegsrhetorik
kennzeichnen die Tonlage für Putin dient
Geschichte als Waffe Stalin bewundert er
seine Propaganda beschwört den Sieg über
Hitler mit der sogenannten
spezial-operation will er die Ukraine
denazifizieren und nun auch Deutschland
wir wissen nicht wie weit Wladimir Putin
gehen würde in seinem Endkampf lang
gegen den Westen das ist eine schwierige
Situation auch wir stehen in gewisser
Weise auf schwankendem Grund und müssen
doch eine feste Position finden ich
glaube der deutsche
Zivil machtspazifismus lass mich in Ruhe
mit Krieg ist historisch an seine
Grenzen gekommen wir müssen anerkennen
wenn man nicht die Ukraine unterstützt
macht man sich auch schuldig weil man
dadurch den Aggressor stärkt es ist
wieder Krieg in Europa was für eine
Tragödie 80 Jahre nach Stalingrad
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den
Nachrichten und mit Gundula
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner hat bei
einem Besuch der Bundeswehrsoldaten im
westafrikanischen Mali auf die Folgen
der hohen Verschuldung viele
Entwicklungsländer hingewiesen das
gefährdet die politische Situation auch
in Westafrika Stabilität dort habe eine
hohe Bedeutung für die Sicherheit
Europas sagte Lindner und forderte mehr
Unterstützung von der malischen
Regierung die zunehmend unter dem
Einfluss Russlands steht der UN-Einsatz
der rund 1100 Bundeswehrsoldaten in Mali
bis Mai 24 ist seit langem umstritten
trotz aller Appelle zur Mäßigung im
israelisch palästinensischen
Dauerkonflikt haben sich beide Seiten
erneut mit Raketen angegriffen die
israelische Armee teilte mit ihre neuen
Luftangriffe Aufstellungen der
radikalislamischen Hamas im Gazastreifen
sein Reaktion auf den Raketenbeschuss
Israels von dort die Palästinenser
machen zugleich immer wieder Israel für
die Eskalation verantwortlich
in Wien sind vier Helfer eines
is-attentäters zu langen Haftstrafen
verurteilt worden zweimal lebenslang und
zweimal bis zu 20 Jahre Haft sie hatten
dem Täter der im November 2020 in Wien
vier Menschen tötete und mehrere
Verletzte Schusswaffen und Munition
besorgt der Attentäter mit albanischen
Wurzeln wurde von der Polizei erschossen
die Angeklagten verschiedener
Nationalitäten hatten Verbindungen zu
Islamisten
nach rund drei Jahren Pandemie sind in
Deutschland weitere corona-maßnahmen
ausgelaufen so müssen Reisende im
öffentlichen nah und im Fernverkehr seit
Mitternacht keine Schutzmaske mehr
tragen damit gilt die maskenpflicht
bundesweit nur noch in Pflegeheimen und
in medizinischen Einrichtungen
jetzt ist es endlich raus nennt sie
Faser tritt bei den Landtagswahlen im
Oktober in Hessen als Spitzenkandidatin
der SPD an Verzeihung sie möchte
hessische Ministerpräsidentin werden
falls das aber nicht klappt will sie
weiterhin ihr Amt als
bundesinnenministerin in Berlin behalten
sie begründete das heute so es ist eine
demokratische Selbstverständlichkeit aus
dem Amt heraus zu kandidieren und das
mache ich ebenso wie Herr Scholz ist
damals als Finanzminister gemacht hat
Frau Merkel aus dem Amt der
Bundeskanzlerin heraus oder Herr Laschet
der damals Ministerpräsident war und im
übrigen wird es auch mein mit Konkurrent
der hessischen Ministerpräsident zu tun
in Berlin guten Abend es gab schon
ziemlich viel Kritik aus anderen
Parteien warum ist die Entscheidung von
Nancy Faser beides zu wollen Ministeramt
und Spitzenkandidatur eine ziemlich
riskante Strategie
er nennt sie Faser macht sich mit dieser
Strategie gleich von zwei Seiten
angreifbar zum einen in ihrer Rolle als
bundesinnenministerin da gibt es selbst
Kritik aus reines Koalitionspartners von
Grünen und FDP da gibt es eine
Befürchtung dass sich Nancy fazer im
Wahlkampf möglicherweise nicht mehr
ausreichend auf ihr Amt konzentrieren
könnte und das in Zeiten in den wirklich
wichtige Aufgaben da stehen und zu
bewältigen sind Extremismus Abwehr Cyber
Kriminalität aber auch Migrationsfragen
sind alles große Aufgaben das konnte sie
mit dem was wir eben im Oden gehört
haben und bekommt dafür auch
Rückendeckung von Olaf Scholz der heute
bei einem Bürger Dialog auf Nachfrage
gesagt hat nennt sie Faser sei eine
pflichtbewusste Frau und sie wird jeden
Tag alles für den Job den sie hat tun so
hat er das ausgedrückt also auf der
Seite hat sie Rückendeckung aus den
eigenen Reihen und vor allem vom Kanzler
und dann gibt es aber eben noch die
zweite Seite die in Hessen spielt wo sie
dann eben als Kandidatin antritt aber
mit der Aussage dass sie nur im Wahlsieg
im Falle des Wahlsiegs zurückkehren will
sie kann sich dort auf einen gewissen
Grad an Bekanntheit verlassen sie ist
lange dort tätig gewesen war zuletzt
Oppositionsführerin bevor sie ins
Bundeskabinett gegangen ist und ist
immer noch
SPD-Landesvorsitzende hat da also eine
Basis das ist anders als im Fall Norbert
Röttgen mit dem sie oft verglichen wird
der hat sich mal auf die Nase gelegt mit
einer Kandidatur in Nordrhein-Westfalen
aus dem Boden aus einem
Bundesministerium heraus aber das Risiko
ist eben da dass die hessischen
Wählerinnen und Wähler ihr nicht
abnehmen dass es eine volle
Herzensangelegenheit ist sondern dass
sie nur halbherzig in den Wahlkampf geht
spätestens im Oktober wissen wir mehr
Dankeschön kunterla energy nach Berlin
im heute journal Update gegen halb eins
sehen sie noch ein Gespräch zum Thema
mit dem stellvertretenden
SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzenden im Bundestag
Dirk Wiese
die Europäische Zentralbank hat den
Leitzins erneut um 0,5% Punkte angehoben
auf jetzt 3%. so wollen die Frankfurter
eurozentralbanker langfristig die
Preissteigerung bekämpfen super könnten
Sie jetzt denken 3% Zinsen aufs
Tagesgeldkonto leider nein die Kredite
werden zwar teurer aber bei den Sparern
kommt die Zinserhöhung nur sehr langsam
an warum das so ist hat sich Markus
wollsifer auch gefragt
Christian Eichenberger war froh die
Pandemie endlich hinter sich zu lassen
der Mittelständler aus dem hessischen
Ober-Mörlen verleiht Möbel für
Veranstaltungen und Messen die Aufträge
sind wieder da doch mit jedem
Zinsschritt wachsen die sorgen jetzt
nach Corona geht es eben für viele darum
sich zu transformieren in die Zukunft zu
investieren die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
wiederherzustellen und vor allem auch in
die Arbeitskräfte und in die Fachkräfte
wieder zu investieren und das kostet
natürlich sehr viel Geld und das ist
unter den jetzigen
Investitionsbedingungen mit steigenden
Zinsen natürlich dann nur noch sehr
schwer möglich die Kredite für all das
hier kamen bisher von der Sparkasse
Oberhessen doch die Gespräche zwischen
Bank und Kunde werden nicht einfacher
wir alle Banken müssen Sie auch hier den
gestiegenen Leitzins an die Kreditkunden
Weitergeben der Blick auf die
vergangenen zwölf Monate zeigt seit der
Zinswende sind die Raten für einen
beispielkredite in Höhe von 10.000 €
deutlich gestiegen auf der anderen Seite
sollten auch die Zinsen für Sparer
steigen die Kurve beim Tagesgeld
deutlich flacher viele Banken in
Deutschland halten sich auffäll zurück
63% Zahlen noch immer keine Zinsen aufs
Tagesgeld das zeigt eine Auswertung des
Vergleichsportals Verivox mancher
spricht bereits von der großen
zinsauerei auch bei der Sparkasse
Oberhessen gibt es keine Zinsen aufs
Tagesgeld der Vorstand erklärt das so
der Kunde kommt nicht zu uns um den
besten Preis zu bekommen denn dafür
stehen wir überhaupt nicht aber wir
fokussieren uns auf die Kunden die sagen
mir geht es gar nicht um den besten
Preis sondern um die beste Beratung kaum
bis gar keine Sparzinsen einige fintechs
wird dann morgen Luft trade Republic z.B
ein Online Broker er zeigt dass es geht
2% aufs Tagesgeld
Digitalisierung und Automatisierung kann
man heute viele Kosten sparen und diese
Vorteile eins zu eins an den Kunden eben
weitergeben und etablierten Banken haben
natürlich gewachsene Strukturen die in
sich teurer sind als die Strukturen die
wir als junges Unternehmen heute haben
also doch alles eine große Sauerei nicht
ganz sagt der zinsexperte Max Herbst er
räumt ein manche Banken und Sparkassen
spekulieren vielleicht dass der Kunde zu
träge ist um zu wechseln doch
verbraucher sollten genau hinschauen
die tollen Zinsen von zwei Prozent über
zwei Prozent sind alles Neukunden
Angebote also er möchte den Neukunden
gewinnen und der Bestand konnte immer
schon seit Jahren hat der kriegt er 0,3
0,4 %. also nicht recht viel mehr wie
bei der Sparkasse
0,5 also ist der Unterschied zwischen
dem tollen Angebot der Geschäftsmann
oder Direktbanken zu den Sparkassen
Volksbanken gar nicht so groß
Unternehmer Christian Eichenberger hofft
dass die EZB die Zinsschraube nicht noch
weiter anzieht doch danach sieht das
nicht aus die Währungshüter wollen die
Inflation weiter zähmen im nächsten
Monat soll bereits der nächste
Zinsschritt kommen
und mit die größten Profiteure aller
bisherigen Zinserhöhungen waren die
europäischen Banken Gundula zum Beispiel
die Deutsche Bank sie hat im vergangenen
Jahr den höchsten Nachsteuergewinn seit
15 Jahren erzielt 5,6 Milliarden Euro
Ergebnis des Konzernumbaus und eben auch
der höheren Zinsen Frank Bethmann an der
Börse wie weit gibt sie denn die Erträge
an die Kunden weiter ja nur bedingt
einige Banken Nutzen in diesen Tagen
schon die Gelegenheit wenn der
öffentliche Fokus auf sie gerichtet ist
genau darauf hinzuweisen Christian
sewing z.B sagte uns am ZDF Mikrofon man
habe ab heute eben auch ein neues
verbessertes Zinsangebot für die Kunden
am Start wir haben gestern übrigens im
Vorgriff auf eine Entscheidung der EZB
unsere Zinsen noch mal um 25 Basispunkte
angehoben von daher sehen Sie dass wir
natürlich weitergeben
wenn auch nicht um bei diesen 25
Basispunkten mal zu bleiben ganz so
zügig und nicht im vollen sondern nur im
halben Umfang schließlich hat die
Europäische Zentralbank die Leitzinsen
ja heute um 50 Basispunkte angehoben
davon mal abgesehen haben die Börse Anna
den Gewinnsprung von Deutschlands
größten Geldhaus zwar zu Erkenntnis
genommen gejubelt aber wurde nicht im
Gegenteil die Aktie der Deutschen Bank
verlor heute kräftig 6,5 % und das war
sebing auf 20 23 doch eher zurückhaltend
die konjunkturentwickler sich mau die
Inflation bleibe hoch den DAX aber
insgesamt störte das wenig das
Aktienbarometer Schloss über 2% höher
bei
15.59 Punkten und kletterte damit auf
das höchste Niveau seit fast einem Jahr
Frank Beckmann vielen Dank
der Holocaust Überlebende Sally Perel
bekannt als Hitlerjunge Salomon ist im
Alter von 97 Jahren gestorben
international bekannt wurde der
gebürtige Deutsche durch seine
Autobiographie ich war Hitlerjunge
Salomon perell wurde in Peine geboren
und überlebte den Holocaust unter
falscher Identität nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg wanderte perell ins heutige
Israel aus wo er jetzt verstarb
im südhessischen Biblis ist der erste
von vier Kühltürmen des stillgelegten
Kernkraftwerks kontrolliert zum Einsturz
gebracht worden
ferngesteuerte Bagger hatten den 80
Meter hohen Turm so lange destabilisiert
ist er in sich zusammenbrach seit 2017
wird das Kernkraftwerk zurückgebaut es
war nach dem Atomausstieg Deutschlands
2011 stillgelegt worden
neuen Mitglieder einer Bande von
Geldautomaten sprengern sind in den
Niederlanden festgenommen worden sie
sollen vor allem in Süddeutschland mehr
als 50 Geldautomaten beschädigt und
dabei mehr als 5 Millionen Euro erbeutet
haben laut Bundeskriminalamt wurden im
vergangenen Jahr insgesamt fast 500
Bankautomaten in Deutschland gesprengt
die Nanas knallbunte übergewichtig
kurvige Frauenskulpturen machten sie
weltbekannt die Künstlerin und
Bildhauerin Nici Fall doch die lustigen
runden Nanas führen in die Irre denn zur
Fall war eine Pionierin eine
aktionskünstlerin die wie hier mit Farbe
auf ihre Bilder erschoss und die eigene
Kunst als Befreiung erlebte von
Unterdrückung Patriarchat und sexueller
Gewalt die schirmkunsthalle Frankfurt
wird mit ihr nun eine umfassende
Retrospektive Inken Klinge hat sich für
uns in den Farbrausch gestürzt
[Musik]
zu Beginn ihres Schaffens schießt Niki
de saint-fall auf Gips Reliefs mit
Farbbeuteln gefüllt ihre Wut richtet
sich Anfang der 60er Jahre gegen die
Konventionen und Machtverhältnisse der
Zeit
sie zielt auf ihren Vater der sie als
Kind missbrauchte auf Männer insgesamt
und Politiker in der Phase des Kalten
Krieges hier Kennedy und Chruschtschow
Fall ist eigentlich eine skandalöse
Künstlerin sie hat es geschafft den
Feminismus auf die Plattform der
zeitgenössischen Kunst zu Hefen sie hat
ein Gewehr genommen um auf Bilder zu
schießen sie hat das Publikum Angeboten
in ihrer Arbeit und sie hat es geschafft
damit die Kunstgeschichte aus der
Perspektive der Frau zu revolutionieren
die Ausstellung in Frankfurt hat das
gesamte Werk der
französisch-amerikanischen Künstlerin im
Blick von frühen Gemälden bis zu ihren
großen Skulpturen den berühmten Nanas
die Identität der Frau beschäftigt Niki
de San Fal ihr Leben lang sie zeigt sie
als Mutter Braut und Ehefrau in
Rollenbildern gefangen und alternd
unzufrieden beim Tee die Autodidaktin
Niki de Sound Fall verließ ihren ersten
Ehemann und ihre Kinder für die Kunst
eine Verbindung blieb Enkelin Blum
kadenas ist stolz auf ihre Großmutter
es war großartig sie als Beispiel zu
haben dass alles möglich ist wenn du die
Vorstellungskraft hast und wenn du stur
genug bist für das zu kämpfen woran du
glaubst dann kann es wahr werden
die drei bunten Nanas sind Nicki des am
Pfalz Befreiungsschlag sie sind
selbstbewusst und stark eine Art
Liebeserklärung an die Weiblichkeit
am Anfang waren auch sie umstritten
besonders eine gewaltige begehbare Nana
die sie unter anderem mit ihrem neuen
Lebenspartner jean-tang Lee schuf
betrachteten 1966 viele als skandalös
doch am Ende gewinnen die fröhlichen
Frauen die Herzen der Betrachter
die nana ist dann diese Figur die so
kraftvoll voluminös erscheint und quasi
wirklich das Jubelfest der Frau ausruft
sie sagt diese Frauen waren unabhängig
frei in ihrer Sexualität frei in ihrer
körperlichen in ihrer Körperlichkeit
unabhängig von Vorstellungen männlicher
Sexualität oder männlichen Vorstellung
zur weiblichen Sexualität
Niki de saunfall brauchte die Kunst als
Therapie sagte sie selbst in ihrem Werk
gab sie viel von sich preis ihren
Schmerz und ihre Lebensfreude
das Jubelfest der Frau das merke ich mir
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
Maybrit Illner sie fragt gleich Ihre
Gäste Arbeitskräfte dringend gesucht wer
sichert Wirtschaft und Wohlstand
wir wünschen einen schönen Abend
wieder bis dahin
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in den Hochlagen
der Alpen kommt einiges an Schnee
zusammen gut ein Meter übers Wochenende
ja und dieser Schnee der staut sich an
den Alpen genauso wie im Bayerischen
Wald das ganze verlagert sich dann aber
allmählich ostwärts bevor neue Regen
aufkommt der dann im Süden an den Alpen
erneut in Schnee übergeht schauen wir
uns das ganze genauer an an den Alpen
also längere Zeit Schneefall teils
ergiebig ganz im Osten in den
Frühstunden auch rutschig durch etwas
Schneefall das Ganze zieht dann ostwärts
und von Westen her wird es Trockner
Temperaturen sinken dabei auf -2 Grad im
Osten Deutschlands und sieben Grad ganz
im Westen morgen erst einmal
Auflockerungen dann kommt Regen auf der
sich langsam südwärts verlagert ja und
dann ein Mädchen Schnee übergeht vorher
gibt es aber sogar noch etwas
Sonnenschein der Schnee staut sich dann
an den alten ja und der Wind kommt des
Nordwest und ist teils stürmisch
Temperaturen dazu höchste Werte 3 Grad
im Vogtland und 10 Grad ganz im Westen
die kommenden Tage weitere Schneefälle
an den Alpen am Samstag auch ergiebig
ganz im Norden zeigt sich auch mal die
Sonne zwei bis zehn Grad am Sonntag
kommt ein neues Schnee tief das rutscht
weiter Richtung Alpen und bringt weitere
Schneefälle und am Montag wird es ein
wenig kälter sein damit ein schöner
Abend